why did you develop the Six stage plot
structure what was the impetus for that
well it's I'm hesitant to say I
developed it it's what I detected when I
watched movie after movie and read
script after script after script and
looked at what consistently happens in
those that are successful successful
commercially and also successful
artistically at least as evidenced by
awards and so on but most of all they're
successful commercially what is it that
happens in movie after movie that
Hollywood is producing that isn't
happening in all those thousands of
scripts that are getting rejected and
when I dug in and picked it apart what I
found was that there are consistently
six stages to any successful story or
any successful movie I should pause here
to say when I talk about when I say any
or always you should translate that to
me 90% of the time because I like to
talk in absolutes and there's always
going to be some exceptions and so on
but so often in a successful movie can
broke be broken into these same six
stages and those stages are created by
the five key turning points and those
turning points always occurred at the
same point in the movie at the same
percentage of the running time so when I
started recognizing it was happening
that consistently then I figured people
need to know about this so I began
lecturing about it and I began
incorporating it into my coaching and
then I studied it more and developed it
into what I call my particular approach
to looking at the structure but it's not
that I was discerning things that are
significantly different from the other
structure that you'll hear so if you
talk to Chris Vogler about his hero's
journey structure or John trilby or Bob
Mackie or Syd fields or whoever it might
be it's not that we're all disagreeing
with each other it's just that as Chris
said one time we're all looking through
different windows at the same thing
we're all looking at the same movies and
the same stories and just looking from
our point of view of how
we simplify this process by by sort of
reducing it down to something that would
be very easy to consistently follow as
you're writing scripts
you